we have got a bunch of quotes half of
them are said by piers morgan and half
of them are said by meghan markle but
will the people here be able to tell the
difference one of them cannot get enough
of the cameras has a complete obsession
with prince harry and is hijacking
absolutely every national event that is
possible the other one is meghan markle
this is morgan or marco
you know who peters morgan is yes good
and you know who making marklers yes
you're fully qualified to play the game
is very simple we've got a bunch of
quotes half of them were said about
piers morgan the other half was said by
meghan markle if you think it's meghan
markle you're gonna do what canada's on
fire if it's piers morgan it's not i've
thought yeah it was sort of one of them
that was quite quick do you like meghan
markle no no no
have you met meghan markle no no but she
still hates her welcome i don't hate her
i just can't stand her ladies and
gentlemen you're seeing it before it's
one of after welcome to morgan markle
with fame comes opportunity was it
morgan or markle
i'm gonna go more again
no that was megan look at the
opportunity she's got there is a certain
advantage to the british accent markle
marco
yes i think it's merkel okay okay morgan
oh that is correct it's a trick well
this is the the whole thing trickster
now you'll realize that eventually it's
morgan or meghan markle who would you
choose can we have a nay for ps morgan
my favorite place in la is manhattan
beach it's an intimate friendly little
beachside city organ or markle chloe
morgan i go with this one are you sure
yes final answer for no answer not the
weakest link so final answer we think
we're really confusing
the week's thing yeah they're two
different shows
that's correct morgan well done she's
dressed like she works at pizza express
but she's good at this let's move on do
you think it's easy for him to do what
he's doing easy for a male american
sporting hero to transition into being a
woman
definitely megan it's very megan
do you think morgan said that it's easy
for someone to transition gender
don't just switch because i said so i
know maybe you should switch
what are you going for
michael incorrect it's morgan morgan was
pro trans rights before it was cool
ladies and gentlemen nobody personifies
the ideals of suffragette heroin emily
pankhurst more than malala i don't even
know what that means a suffragette yeah
it's that word they're the ones that
gave you the right to vote and i know
they're regretting it too morgan or
marco um
morgan indeed he did guys i'm really
sorry but we can't have you in the
background standing there so there's a
camera there by all means watch but over
there with the ordinary people thanks
sorry that's grand thank you
okay come all the way from argentina for
that i preferred london during covid
are the lose open morgan or
an easy marco have a lovely time in the
lose thank you i knew i'd end up in show
business in some capacity eventually
morgan that was markle oh you see piers
you're way more similar than you think
yeah they are so it would seem that
piers morgan and meghan markle are far
more similar than either of them would
care to admit that was who said it
morgan or markle bye
never easy getting out of a deck chair
you